foreign
why would a review make the point of
saying someone's not a genius you think
I'm especially not a genius
I don't you
you didn't even have to think about it
did you well
I just don't use that word lightly
I have to go Eli
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Mark Ellis today we're
taking a look at some memorable movie
families but not just any families these
are the most dysfunctional we'll be
focusing on the families more so than
the movies because really nothing makes
you feel better about your own family
than sitting around together and
watching ones that have way more stuff
going on and whether it's inviting the
in-laws over for a good old-fashioned
family Christmas that goes very wrong or
interrogating a family to figure out
which one may have killed its patriarch
this list has all the dysfunctional
family fun you can handle and yeah I'm
gonna say the word dysfunction or
dysfunctional a lot so it's unavoidable
this is what the families give us and
with that here is our list of the most
dysfunctional movie families the
tannenbaums the Royal Tenon bombs here I
come
Eli just crashed his car into the front
of the house oh my God
where's my shoe and kicking off this
list is the Tenenbaum family from 2001's
the Royal Tenon bombs this film was
directed by Wes Anderson who co-wrote it
with Owen Wilson and follows the lives
of the gifted Tenenbaum siblings Ben
Stiller is Chaz Gwyneth Paltrow is
Margot and Luke Wilson as Richie after
being successful as kids they are now
experiencing disappointment and failure
in adulthood welcome to the club their
eccentric father Royal Tenenbaum played
by Gene Hackman left them as adolescence
but later returns claiming to have a
terminal illness and looking to
reconcile with his ex-wife ethelene
played by Angelica Houston Wes Anderson
Drew in his own parents divorce as the
starting point for this concept and then
this story evolved into something else
altogether he pulled from a number of
influences like Orson welles's 1942 film
The Magnificent Amberson about a wealthy
family with plenty of Baggers he has a
cancer
no he doesn't
I know what stomach cancer looks like
I've seen it
and you don't eat three cheeseburgers a
day with french fries if you got it
the pain is excruciating
how would you know
my wife had it
not only is there no Dr McClure at Kobe
General there is no Kobe General
it closed in 1974. oh [ __ ] man the
dysfunction in this family starts with
Hackman's Royal Tenenbaum which as
Anderson put it was written for him
against his wishes and it actually took
some convincing from Hackman's agent to
take the part as he couldn't find any
commonalities with the character he
would go on to win a Golden Globe for
the performance once Hackman was on
board the rest of the star-studded cast
fell into place which also includes Bill
Murray and Danny Glover adding to the
dysfunction of it all F Lynn was written
with Angelica Houston in mind and is
Loosely based on Anderson's own mother
who became an archaeologist after
divorcing his father Ben Stiller and
Gwyneth Paltrow meanwhile two very big
stars at the time only had a small
window to make this film happen due to
other projects so filming worked around
their schedules along with the actors
bringing this story of a seemingly
functional family turned dysfunctional
one to life was an oscar-nominated
screenplay by Anderson and Wilson The
Griswolds National Lampoon's Christmas
Vacation
just can't believe you're actually
standing here in my living room Eddie
never thought the day would come yeah
I'm excited about it too
it's a crying shame the older kids
couldn't make it
I'll get that don't worry about it
and I'm brightening up this list with 25
000 incandescent bulbs is the Griswold
family from 1989's National Lampoon's
Christmas Vacation the third installment
in National Lampoon's Vacation film
series was written and co-produced by
John Hughes and it features Chevy Chase
reprising his role as Clark Griswold
whose combination of optimism and denial
only adds to the chaos surrounding his
family while his always supportive yet
not always agreeable wife Ellen is once
again played by Beverly Daniel and this
time the franchise had some memorable
turns from the kids whose revolving door
of actors from film to film included
Juliet Lewis as Audrey and a young
Johnny Galecki as rust for this one her
dislike of all things related to big
family Christmas and his overall
annoyance by the relatives are vital
pillars to this family's Tower of
dysfunction and and I want to look I'm
straight in the eye I don't want to tell
them what a cheap lying no good rotten
for flushing low-life snake licking dirt
eating inbred over stuffed ignorant
blood sucky dog kissing brainless
hopeless heartless fat bug-eyed
stiff-legged spotty lip worm-headed sack
of monkeys he is
hallelujah holy [ __ ] where's the Tylenol
and while that core 4 definitely has
their own issues the real drama in this
one comes from the extended family who
pretty much all show up some invited
some not to spend the holidays at the
Griswold Manor some of the analogs
include Everybody Loves Raymond star
Doris Roberts as Ellen's mother and Mae
questel aka the voice of Betty Boop as
Clark's 80 year old senile Aunt Bethany
then there's Randy Quaid as Cousin Eddie
reprising his role from the first
vacation film and putting forth one of
the most memorable character
performances in Christmas movie history
and by showing up unexpectedly with his
family and dog named snot and their
dirty RV I mean that really puts the fun
in family dysfunction the thrombies
knives out likewise the house at two
Dearborn Drive in all belongings therein
I leave to Marta Cabrera
oh oh you little
[ __ ]
did you know about this were you in on
this from this example I just want to
know what were you what were you doing
were you pointing my father a pointy
adding some mystery to this list is the
thrombi family from 2019's Knives Out
the film was written and directed by
Ryan Johnson his first film after
directing The Last Jedi and revolves
around the death of 85 year old
best-selling crime novelist Harlan
thrombi played by Christopher Plummer in
the last movie he filmed before his
death what happened to Harwin is unknown
and given the level of dysfunction in
this family it becomes quite the Web of
Lies to sift through in order to figure
out who may have been responsible the
Stacked cast of suspects family members
includes Jamie Lee Curtis's Linda
harwin's oldest daughter along with her
husband Richard played by Don Johnson on
the day of his death Harlan had
threatened to expose Richard for
cheating on Linda they have a son Ransom
played by Chris Evans who had recently
had an altercation with his grandfather
harwin's youngest son Walt thrombi who
was just fired from harwin's publishing
company is played brilliantly by Michael
Shannon Ryan Johnson said he was by far
the funniest person on set and came up
with a lot of his characters funny
moments nothing good is ever easy
up your ass Johnny you've had your teeth
in this family's for a long time
[Applause]
also adding to the dysfunction is any
winner Tony Colette as Joanie thrombi
the Widow of harwin's deceased son and
whose allowance was caught off by Harlan
the very day he died all that family and
all that drama helped turn this one into
a surprise Mega hit when the resulted in
a huge deal with Netflix for two sequels
from Ryan Johnson
the Hoovers Little Miss Sunshine
and that's when
excited to check out early
yes yes and I failed at that as well
Olive the important thing to understand
here is that Uncle Frank gave up on
himself
he made a series of foolish choices I'm
sorry and he gave up on himself which is
something the winners never do taking
their family dysfunction on the road for
this list is the Hoover from 2006's
Little Miss Sunshine this film marks the
directorial debut of husband wife team
Jonathan Dayton and Valerie Farris best
known for music videos at the time and
the screenplay was written by first time
writer Michael arnt who would go on to
tackle all kinds of different families
in films like Toy Story 3 and Star Wars
the Force awakens Little Miss Sunshine
revolves around the dysfunction that
occurs among the Hoover family after
they all pile into a VW van for a road
trip to take the young Olive Hooper
played by Abigail Breslin to a beauty
pageant the family on the trip includes
Greg kinnear's Richard Hoover Iowa's
father and a type A personality who's
trying to become a successful life coach
Thomas Hayden Church turned down the
role before Kinnear was cast Richard's
wife Cheryl played by Tony Collette is
an overworked mom of two who's welcomed
her brother Frank played by Steve Carell
to live with them after he attempted
suicide the role of Frank was reportedly
written with Bill Murray in mind and
there was also pressure from the studio
to cast Robin Williams but Corel ended
up with the gig after a meeting with the
directors who were weary of his comedy
background but found that he totally
understood the tone of the film and his
character anyway he uh
gets down to the end of his life
it's back and decides that all those
years he suffered those were the best
years of his life because they made him
who he was
all the years he was happy you know
total waste
didn't learn a thing
so if you sleep until you're 18 ah
think of the suffering You're Gonna Miss
I mean high school high school those are
your Prime suffering years
I don't get better suffering than that
but that ain't all the dysfunction folks
because this van also included Richard's
foul mouth father Edwin who lives with
the family after being evicted from a
retirement home for Yes you heard this
correctly snorting heroin and we also
got Cheryl's son Dwayne from a previous
marriage played by Paul Dano who's taken
a vow of silence there's nothing like a
van full of family working through their
issues although I do know who's going to
win the silent game this family
dysfunction did prove quite success with
the box office and the film was also
nominated for four Academy Awards
including best picture and one best
original screenplay and supporting actor
for Alan Arkin plus the Hoover family
took home the Screen Actors Guild award
for outstanding performance by a cast
and a motion picture the mcdonas Raising
Arizona and we followed them busted out
of jail no ma'am uh we released on our
own recognizings whatever here is trying
to say is that we felt the institution
no longer had anything to offer Us My
Lord he's cute he's a little Outlaw you
can see that high now listen you folks
can't stay here
ma'am you just can't stay now I
appreciate you being friends of high and
all but this is a decent family now
next up on our list the most
dysfunctional families is the McDonald's
from 1987's Raising Arizona the film was
written directed and produced by
Brothers Joel and Ethan Cohen in just
their second feature after the 1984
crime drama Blood Simple this one
revolves around the McDonald's starting
with Nicholas Cage's High he's a common
convenience store robber who yearns to
live life on the straight and narrow
after he marries a former police officer
Ed McDonough played by Holly Hunter of
course the next con and the next cop
doesn't necessarily spell family
dysfunction but in this case because of
their inability to have kids on their
own they decide to take matters into
their own hands by stealing a baby from
a rich family set of quintuplets and
from there the dysfunction just gets
more Amplified the Cohen Brothers wrote
the character of Ed specifically for
future Oscar winner and friend Holly
Hunter in one of her earliest feature
film roles but when it comes to high
McDonough Kevin Costner actually
auditioned for the role three times
before Nicholas Cage was eventually cast
man listen up what's the matter don't
you get it
no Glenn I sure don't man I guess that's
why they call it a way Homer well is
that because you only get it on the way
home
I'm already home
you wet yourself you went
brother complicating the family dynamic
between the mcdonas is the outside
interference from characters like biker
Leonard Smalls played by pro boxer
Randall Tex Cobb and his old cellmates
eval and Gail snows played by William
Forsyth and John Goodman respectively
Oscar winner Francis McDormand a former
roommate of hunters at the Yale School
of drama also appears in this film as
dot another person tried to spoil the
mcdonough's plan and let's not forget
about the baby Nathan Jr who would have
truly completed this dysfunctional
family had the mcdonough's plan work 15
different babies were used to make up
the quintuplets in the movie with one
reportedly being let go after learning
how to walk it's a Cutthroat business is
Hollywood the McAllister's home alone
you're completely helpless everyone has
to do everything for you she's right Kev
excuse me pupils I'm a lot smaller than
you I don't know how to pack a suitcase
hey I hope you didn't just pack crap
Jeff shut up Lenny do you know what I
should pack I was told your cheek face
toilet paper and water
listen Kev what are you so worried about
you know mom's gonna pack your stuff
anyway
you're what the French call Liz and
competent what and not getting left
behind on this list is the McAllister
family from 1990s Home Alone the film is
directed by Chris Columbus a couple
years after making his debut with
Adventures in Babysitting it stars
Macaulay Culkin as Kevin a member of the
mcalisters who makes a wish that he
doesn't have a family and then he wakes
up lo and behold to find himself in a
big empty house not realizing that his
family accidentally left them behind
when they took off in a hurry to the
airport writer John Hughes who conceived
the film while preparing for vacation
and wondering what would happen if he
left his son behind suggested that they
cast Culkin after his experience with
the actor on Uncle Buck director
Columbus met with 200 other actors for
the part of Kevin comedian and actor
John Mulaney was asked to audition but
his parents declined before Culkin was
ultimately given the role and of course
Kevin's parents at home alone played by
John Hurt and Catherine O'Hara don't
scream dysfunction on the surface but
they did forget one of their kids so you
know if it makes you feel better
Catherine O'Hara did say in 2014 that
Macaulay Culkin still calls her mom some
of the other big contributors to the
dysfunction of the McAlister's includes
Kevin's older brother Buzz played by
Devin retrey and Kevin's youngest cousin
Fuller played by Macaulay Culkin's
brother Kieran Colgan but if you've seen
hum alone as many times as we all have
you know the real dysfunction all stems
from One Source Uncle Frank the role was
written for Kelsey Grammer but later
given to Jerry bammon when grammar was
unavailable so Bama got to deliver one
of the movie's best lines she started it
hit my pizza on purpose he knows that
it's sausage and olives look what you
did you little jerk
and of course we would get more of Uncle
Frank as this film was followed by a
sequel in 1992 Home Alone 2 lost in New
York which brought most of the original
films cast back and all that dysfunction
with it
the Westins August Osage County father
and I first in our families to graduate
high school and he wound up an
award-winning poet
you girls just give it a college
education take it for granted no doubt
where'd you wind up
what do you do
what do you do
who are you
Jesus you worked as hard as us you know
me president you have no real problem
say you got to make all your problems
yourself arriving in what could be
considered the late summer of this list
is the Westin family from 2013's August
Osage County the movie was directed by
John Wells who developed the series
Shameless for Showtime two years earlier
a show known for having one of the most
dysfunctional families ever seen on
television in this film after The
Disappearance of their father Beverly
Weston played by Sam Shepard the
family's three adult daughters go back
to the Oklahoma house they grew up in
and to the dysfunctional mother they
grew up with who is of course a sharp
tongued pill pop and cancer patient
Violet Weston played by Meryl Streep
screenwriter Tracy Letts vetoed a studio
exec's idea of Judy dench's Violet
actresses like Jane Fonda Glenn Close
and Annette Benning were then considered
for the role before Streep stepped in as
far as the daughters go they clearly
took plenty of their mom's dysfunctional
ways with them into adulthood with more
baggage being unpacked as the film goes
on
do me the courtesy of recognizing when I
am demeaning you Violet really is a way
of putting you in attack mode you know
that you feel such rage for her don't go
analyze me well you may not like my
methods but you know I'm right your
methods
thank you doctor I don't actually need
my mother's help to feel rage you want
to argue is that what you need to do
then pick a subject all right let me
know what it is so I have a fighting
chance I am the subject the subject is
me Julia Roberts plays the oldest
daughter Barbara who's married to Ewan
McGregor's Bill and with Abigail Breslin
as their daughter Jean who beat out
Chloe Grace Moretz for the role then
there's Julianne Nicholson as Ivy the
middle daughter and Julia Lewis is Karen
Weston the youngest of the three Lewis
actually replaced Andrea rise bro who
was cast but dropped out due to
scheduling conflicts and yes it is quite
hilarious that these three daughters are
played by actresses named Julia Julianne
and Julia rounding out the family
dysfunction to varying degrees is
characters like Violet's sister Maddie
Faye played by Emmy winner of Margo
Martindale and Benedict Cumberbatch as
her son little Charles we get
Cumberbatch in this movie too and while
the cast as a whole was nominated for a
sag award deservedly so the real core of
this film's drama strip and Roberts were
both nominated for Oscars golden and
globes and SAG Awards for their
respective leading and supporting
performances you see good things can
Rise Up from a dysfunctional family the
solitanos Silver Linings Playbook what
the [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
I just can't believe Nikki's teaching
that book to the kids I mean it's the
whole time let me just break it down for
you the whole time you're rooting for
this Hemingway guy to survive the war
and to be with the woman that he loves
Catherine Barkley it's four o'clock in
the morning dancing their way onto this
list next is the solitano family from
2012's Silver Linings Playbook the movie
stars Bradley Cooper as Pat solitano Jr
a man with bipolar disorder who winds up
living back at his home with his parents
after losing his job and his wife and
spending time in a mental institution
meanwhile Pat senior and Dolores
solitano played by Robert De Niro and
Jackie Weaver along with their other son
Jake played by Shea Wiggum are seemingly
more interested in Pat Jr sharing their
love for the Philadelphia Eagles then
rebuilding his life so Pat Jr turns to a
young Widow named Tiffany played by
Jennifer Lawrence for help the film was
written and directed by David O Russell
who said he rewrote the script roughly
20 times and was drawn to the story
because of the family relationships and
a connection he felt to his own son when
it comes to the display function of the
solitanos Russell would shoot multiple
versions of scenes with De Niro's
character operating at various levels of
harshness allowing Russell to find the
right balance of dysfunction during the
editing process
I want to do everything I can to help
you get back on your feet that's that's
that's the whole point
we should watch these games with me I
said we could talk but we could
get into things
foreign
we just come downstairs and talk to me
and Randy now huh for the character of
Pat Jr Russell was looking at Vince
Vaughn and later Mark Wahlberg for the
part the latter of which ultimately had
to drop out after production delays so
Bradley Cooper landed the role Cooper
said at the time that he was feeling
heavier and more Angry in his life and
he would Channel those qualities for the
character and as we've clearly learned
today a great combination for
dysfunctional family seems to be great
acting and writing which this one
clearly had among its eight Oscar
nominations was one each for De Niro
Weaver and Cooper not to mention best
directing best adapted screenplay and
best picture Russell did pick up a bafta
award for his screenplay and top Rotten
Tomatoes critic Bob Mondello from
npr.org called him just the guy to bring
and then calm the manic dysfunction in
these folks and as a nice Capper hey the
Eagles are doing well this season the
grants Nebraska
damn you hit the Powerball
show us the ticket Uncle Woody honestly
he didn't win anything
I didn't want anything I don't blame you
Woody I wouldn't broadcast it either
not till I had it in the bank
you have to watch out for buzzards too
and Barton me we can drive you
sure we can get you to Lincoln in an
hour and the final family included on
this list of the most dysfunctional
movie families is the grants from 2013's
Nebraska the film was directed by
Alexander Payne who is a couple years
removed from The Descendants which has
plenty of family dysfunction in its own
right this one centers around Woody
Grant played by Bruce Dern a
cantankerous old man in Billings Montana
who gets a sweepstakes notice in the
mail so he tries to drag his son David
played by Will Forte on the 750 mile
road trip to Lincoln Nebraska to collect
this prize the immediate Grant family
also includes June Squibb as Woody's
wife Kate and Bob Odenkirk as their
oldest son Ross as Woody's insistence
that he is about to be rich grows more
issues arise within the family
especially when Woody goes from a hero
to a Target while passing through his
hometown look Aunt Betty guys hey for
real honestly right
Woody didn't win anything this is a
total sham
you're a damn liar sending your [ __ ]
Ross
well you want to go
let's do it
hey hey hey hey
watch my face okay I'm on TV
when it comes to Dern he was pretty much
one of Payne's first choices for the
role of the Grant Family patriarch
although to please the suits Payne met
with actors like Robert De Niro and
Robert Forster who both turned it down
which led back to Dern the role of David
was a desired one around town with Brian
Cranston reading for it and others being
considered like Paul Rudd and Casey
affler but Russell went with Forte who
is considered much less high profile
than what was expected but he delivered
nonetheless and this film and its
dysfunctionally fantastic family clearly
made an impact Nebraska earned six Oscar
nominations including best picture Best
Director best actor for Dern best
supporting actress for Squibb and best
original screenplay for writer Bob
Nelson plus the Grant Family picked up
best ensemble cast awards at both the
satellite Awards and the Boston Society
of film critics Awards which is almost
as cool as you know actually winning
that Nebraska Sweepstake well there you
have it all you functional folks out
there are a list of the most
dysfunctional families in movies so
which one is your favorite or which one
did we leave off Harry and the
Hendersons which movie gonna throw on
next time you and the fam are sitting
around the TV together eating popcorn
and wanting to feel better about your
own situation I know I'm asking a lot of
questions here it's no wonder my family
doesn't talk to me I'm kidding they love
me thanks for watching Mom and thank you
for tuning in to RT Essentials I'm your
semi-functional host Mark Ellis looking
forward to not saying the word
dysfunction ever again early for quite
some time
[Music]